Hi all.
Welcome back. Hi, Esh. Hi.
After a long time. Yeah, yeah. Good to see you all.
Good evening all. Yeah.
Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Hope all of you have, uh, reenergize it well
after the long break.
Uh, yes, we're ready for
long next al rural course ions.
Yes, and we are ready,
also ready to visit campus.
Almost welcome. Most welcome. Looking forward for that.
So how, how all of your
performance was in the first semester.
Okay, good. Yeah.
Uh, good evening to
Good evening. Good evening, Sunil.
Good, good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good.
Uh, So Neil?
Yes, sir. So, uh, um,
first I'll explain the course plan
and then we'll go to the, what is the plan
First we'll, uh, present the course plan.
Hmm. Uh, most of the things are same,
but, uh, what is the syllabus percent all we can discuss?
Oh. And, uh, then we can move to the first,
uh, third part.
I also have some, and so on the like, touch
Yeah, yeah. Some
introduction and all that. We,
Okay.
So maybe I will share the screen
for the first, uh, this one.
Yes. So lemme
Share screen.
This is a common course now for all
Common course for all. Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
This link is same for all sessions, or,
Uh, I'll have to check sir,
because they have given one, uh, sheet where, ah, sheet,
Uh, everybody, uh, the different links are,
um, mentioned there.
So that's where I just curious to understand.
Okay. Let me start.
Um, so Sunil, shall we start? Yes, sir. We can start.
Yeah. Yeah. So good evening all,
and, um, uh, Dr.
Sunil and myself, we will you back to the, uh, journey
for the second semester.
Um, good evening, sir. Thank you. Thank you.
Good evening, all good evening all.
Hope you all had a, a
good experience in the first semester.
The fact that no, you completed the first semester
and continuing for the second semester.
I think by this time, you know the rules of the game.
I think you will be able
to do well in the following semester.
Even if there are any challenges in the first semester,
you don't have to bother now,
now there are no uncertainties, you know,
the system you will be able to handle.
So that is the point I wanted to say.
Uh, so this, uh, this deep learning course
is one of the, uh, know, cornerstone course for
data science and ai.
And, uh, this is the course that, um, Dr.
Sunil and myself will be handling
and which is, uh, no, uh, initially we thought, no,
for all super specializations it'll be common,
but now we all of you, we should
to take generative way in that way.
Uh, most of them, at least some of the other super,
anything this do deep inherently any
of the super specialization, the, the technologies
that we use should be using this deep planning models.
So that is where that becomes a common course.
And it's a three credit course,
and we are going to quickly, in this slide deck,
we'll explain about the, uh, course plan
and then genesis for this deep learning.
Then we'll move on to the first module.
Even though, uh, far from your course point of view,
our slide deck, our videos
and the, uh, toolkits, what, uh, Sunil server will explain,
will suffice you.
But if you on your own, if you have
interest in collecting some good set of books, um,
towards machine learning
and deep learning, uh, you can
look at these books list, which are given.
These are not for your, uh, uh, your courses.
It's only just since we know them for a long time, uh,
we are suggesting them.
You better know.
I think many of them are available
as PDF copies in the public domain.
You can download and keep it.
Um, so, but one thing, at least personally I
referred while teaching deep learning
is this Professor ESH RAs course and course part one
and two from IT Address and Ali, professor Ali go see Course
and Deep Learning from University of Waterloo.
These are publicly available.
I used to watch them based around that.
My experience I will be sharing,
but the latest book on deep learning also has come from a
well-known author called Bishop Deep Learning in 2024 desk.
So all these things are know, available, probably know, just
to know if some of you want to go beyond comfort zone
and want to have, you can have these copies piece,
but a course point of view.
These are not very, you know, uh, instead of interest
of time, everything, we give you the slide deck
with your lectures as well as the hands-on.
So one of the things, uh, uh, Dr.
Il and myself had several sessions session on
how do we handle this course.
If I go, um, I think my experience
of handling this deep learning
and many other colleagues initial offerings,
people started offering these deep learning courses starting
in 2017, 18 and onwards.
At that point, it is more on no explaining the modules,
uh, how a particular deep mod deep learning model works
as something it used to become boring after some time.
Okay? So that is where we thought, no, how,
since you're all are working professionals, how to
give maximum benefit of this course.
So that's where know after discussion, uh, Dr.
Sunil suggested we should, uh, make this course
as more hands on, such that no, you also,
once you are completing this course, you also have exposure
of some open source toolkit
for training and testing.
The deep learning models, which will be useful
for you from a career point of view, are
your company itself.
And, uh, second thing is you will have more clarity on
what we are discussing as a part of theory.
Uh, you assign this open source toolkit, so in that way
that arch is open source toolkits that, uh,
you can make yourself.
And no, by that time, you'll also become comfortable.
Maybe some of you concept, you may use it
for your project also
and, uh, maybe later semester for other courses,
course projects also, that's where we want to make it
more hands-on oriented and less on theory.
Um, so based on our experience, we used to teach only theory
for the whole semester.
And, uh, we not paying much attention for
a lab component now that that is being included as a part
of, um, this course.
And the topic that we are going to discuss is, uh, uh,
brief introduction to neural networks
because some terminologies
of neural networks are relevant when I'm using the
deep learning concepts.
Then, we'll, that is a quick introduction
of important measures of neural networks.
Then we'll migrate
to next level the first deep learning model,
what are called deep feet for neural networks.
In each of these cases now we'll have some examples.
You should run on the arch
and, uh, experience then deep P four networks.
Then the most, uh,
successful deep learning model was con
conversion neural networks.
We discuss about the conversion neur networks
and, uh, then we move on to recurrent neural networks
and its variants like, uh, well-known variant
of recurrent networks in the long short term memory.
That's what we are going to, uh, discuss and also implement.
Then one of the breakthrough results, which came
after this, uh, recurrent networks was
what are called transformers, which gave a big boost
to the deep learning field
and gave birth to a new subfield called generative ai.
And that is what is the transformer
architectures we are going to discuss.
Of course, there are some, these gen transformers,
we can use it as generative models,
and there are some generative other earlier generative
models for their like variation, auto end codes,
generative adverse networks, those things we are going
to discuss, um, um,
uh, this one, uh, uh, the most important thing,
if you have done the deep learning courses,
it should be very comfortable with conventional networks.
You should be very comfortable with LS team.
You should be comfortable, very working, uh, experience
with the transformers and generative address networks.
So that should be the take home message for all
of you when you are gone through this course.
The, uh, organization of delivery
for this course is like this in the first starting from
today, uh, this week and the next week.
So we are going to, uh, in this week,
we are quickly take you through the essential terminologies
of neural networks.
What is artificial neural network neuron, artificial neuron,
basic computing element in the neural network?
Then what are these neural networks?
What are the basic learning laws
that are employed in the neural networks
and implement one well-known neuron model called perception
in the, uh, this one.
And then we move on to feedforward neur networks,
and there is a well known algorithm
for training the Feedforward network called
propagation algorithms.
Then we will study about the B application algorithm
by building a two layer neural network, using
that is the plan for the, this week and the next week.
And followed by that a deep feed for NEUR networks,
which is an extension of a larger network from the simple
Shalon neural network that we study.
In the first two weeks. We discuss about, uh, training
of the, uh, deep neural networks
and the challenges that we face
and, uh, an important concept called vanishing gradients
that we are going to discuss and on we'll, uh,
practically gain experience on training a deep neur network
model on a a hundred digit database,
well known database called S dataset.
And then again, no,
we will discuss about a greedy layer wise training,
which is a well known method for
training the deep neural networks
because of observing the limitation
of vanishing gradient problem occurring
by the BAP propagation
and, uh, training the deep belief networks,
which is the GRE lady.
There was training method was originally used in the belief
network that we are going to dis
and what are the practical tricks we should imply
to train a deeper network layer wise pre-training demo
effective depth that we're gonna discuss.
So in the first four weeks, we are going to cover
up to deep feet for network training, two weeks
for neur network introduction,
and two weeks for defi s At the end
of four weeks are we conducting the first quiz
summit? So Neil,
Uh, sir, we have one quiz.
Ah, Uh, yes sir. So anyway, I can only one quiz.
Okay, we'll see that later.
So then in the, uh, the first two weeks, you can
Take a call that I have,
We'll discuss and we have to announce well in at once
and a week three, we'll jump into Conversional networks
and about two weeks we'll spend on Conversional networks.
What is the difference between a conventional network versus
the other deep for networks or other shallow networks?
What are the basic principles of conversional networks?
That is what we are going to explain theory topics.
And we are going to, uh, in the HandsOn in the arch,
we'll talk about, we implement the manual conation part,
visualizing the filters that we use in design
of filters in case of correction works.
Then we'll discuss about the other part module called
pooling, uh, and, uh, CNN striding
and then CNN training pipeline
and trying a simple CNN network.
Then conversion networks are one of their, uh, major
application of conversion network is feature extractor
and also as classifier.
These are the two, typically we talk about it
as a classifier,
but it is equally well known
for its feature extraction capabilities also.
And that is where, uh, we are in a hands-on thing.
We talk about using the pre-trained, uh,
conventional network for feature extraction.
And, uh, one task we take significance
of conventional network and object classification task,
like error analysis, confusion metrics.
Uh, tho those things we are going to discuss.
So two weeks on basic new network,
two weeks on CNN
because of its significance in the
practical application scenario.
Then we'll move on to what are called the sequence models.
Okay? Essentially, um,
if you take, uh, either simple neural networks
or deeper networks, a conversion neur network,
they essentially model the information that is present
among the distribution
of the feature vectors or data points.
But if the discriminatory information is in the sequence
temporal order or the order in which it is there, okay?
Uh, and those are not modeled
by the conventional conventional networks,
but many machine learning tasks
or deep learning tasks are AI
applications are at broader level.
You see, they also need to exploit the
sequence knowledge to do certain tasks,
certain classification tasks, maybe to discriminate
among the two classes, the information.
Maybe they're in the sequence knowledge
rather than the distribution.
So that is the practically people have seen.
For example, I am trying
to search a one,
but I will go back to my, uh, traditional, uh, example.
Supposedly if, if I want to learn
and train a deep learning model
to recognize the mobile number of, uh,
person in the entry application field, the, if you see,
know, all our mobile phones are 10 digits, all of them use
zero to nine only.
Then how do I distinguish between one mobile number
to the other mobile number?
It's only the temporal order
or in the order not temporal order.
That is the order in which
that 10 digits have been assigned are aligned.
And that is the sequence knowledge, the discrimination
between Uber mobile and my mobile number.
If I go by only digits,
we have only those 10 digits only chosen out
of those 10 digits.
But the unique distinction
between the two mobile number comes
because of the, the, the sequence in which
how these 10 digits have been arranged.
And that is where, uh,
modeling the sequence knowledge from the
incoming data becomes very important.
That's where neural network architectures proposal,
and those are called as a recurrent neural networks.
And that is what we are going to discuss about that
and the basic recurrent network architecture
and some hands-on work followed by that.
The variance of recurrent networks are
what are called long short-term memory lium networks
and gated recurrent units.
Those things we are going to discuss in the sixth week.
So in that way, the standard recurrent network
and its variance, LSTM
and GRE we are going to discuss in fifth
and the sixth, uh, weeks.
Then people, people move on
to the next two version of sequence models.
Those are called a sequence to sequence models,
which is essentially next level of task where I'm going
to match two sequences, okay?
And learn the relationship among the two sequences so that
during testing, if I give one of those input sequences,
I should be able to derive the, uh,
the target output sequence.
For example, I want to do a machine translation of a text
sentence given in say, English to Hindi,
and that is that sequence
to sequence modeling I'm talking about.
Okay? And that is whereas here in a given sequence
derive the knowledge was the first level of sequence models.
Now we are moving on to sequence to sequence models,
and there is something called encoder decoder
architecture comes into picture.
And then as an improvement
or encoder decode architecture,
there's something called attention modeling.
Uh, then, uh, then from the attention modeling, there is a,
uh, next to significantly deviant version K,
what are called transformers.
They also meant for modeling the sequence information,
but without exploiting the RNNR variance, uh,
even sequence to sequence model.
Also, people use RNNR variance. It has its own limitations.
How to overcome that result in what are called
this transformer architectures.
These are also enco decode architecture,
but internally they don't use recurrent
network current variance.
And that's what we are going to discuss in the up to
eight weeks about.
That's all, uh, sequence model.
And in the, because of the importance of
transformer in the generative framework in the ninth
and, uh, uh, 10th week no transformer architecture,
we discuss in detail transformer training.
We discuss, then we'll discuss about transformer
architecture, like machine translation, question
and answer enable entity recognition.
Then the attention variance we discuss,
that is how up to 10 weeks that sequence models will go.
Then after that, we are going
to talk about generative models.
Okay, what are these generative models?
Uh, something what are called variation, auto encoder,
generative adversarial network.
And, uh, then we have generative pre-trained transformer,
which is the very end of the transformer,
which is acting as generative model.
That is what we are going to cover up to 13 weeks.
And depending on the time available, we'll go
for this advance topics and code demo in the 14th week.
So this is how organized, uh, the,
the course, uh, syllabus, uh, in this 14 weeks
coming to the engage base engagement based components,
it is almost like, uh, uh, previous time only
and, uh, slide variations.
Uh, we have done for the class nodes,
we have increased it from 10% to 15%,
because since you regularly put the effort, all of you,
it should be given more weightage.
Whereas the X factor, which is 15%, we have brought it down
to 10%, but overall the same 35% will remain.
Then there is an assignment focus on implementing algorithms
and analyzing results.
That is hands-on part that will have 20%.
Then we'll have three return examination.
One is quiz, 10% weightage.
Um, then, um,
which is know maybe our four weeks
or into the program at the end of four weeks,
we do it midem.
After 7, 8, 8 weeks, we'll conduct the midem
and will do it at the end of the, so week two, this week,
one to seven, maybe week four
or three will take week four,
maybe quiz one, end of week four.
And, uh, nem will be at the end of the semester.
And these written examinations assignments all together
will constitute 65% of the weight.
Okay. Um,
so this is about the course planning and evaluation plan.
Um, any, any questions here from any of you?
Okay, I will, I will move.
I'll just briefly tell about the genesis of deep learning,
then we'll quickly move on.
This is only, you know, historical development.
You don't have to bother too much about this. Okay.
Just to connect, give you a big picture of, uh,
uh, deep how this field of deep learning evolved.
See, the deep learning itself, uh,
they did not use the word deep learning at that point
of time, but they called it
as advanced neural network architectures.
And, uh, conceptually they told no,
they have much more capabilities than conventional neural
networks that are prevalent at that point of time,
like feed four network, deeply belief networks,
uh, compared to them.
These, uh, advanced topics, which essentially know, um,
expanded versions of the conventional network models should,
will have much more what we call, um,
um, capability to ingest large amount of data.
Um, I'm trying to search for a word.
Uh, so the advanced architectures
will have, uh, the capability
to ingest much more data than
what the conventional unit network models are doing.
So as a result, when it is able to ingest more amount
of data, then it is possible that, uh,
know they capture more information.
So, accordingly, we may significantly improve the
performance of any machine learning task.
That was the proposal as early as nineties itself.
But what happened was, uh, people were not able
to demonstrate that significant improve in the performance
by the deeper architectures as advanced network models.
That's where the interest in the, uh,
these advanced architectures went down,
that people abandoned that field.
But some few people,
especially Jeffrey intern group in University of Toronto,
who has been given Nobel Award also on this work
also, uh, he has been given the Tour Award.
All these things are being given, um,
to recognize his country.
He is one of the re core recipient of that, uh,
that all these, those three, uh, people,
their group continue to work on, um,
uh, know how do these advanced architectures can be trained
and exploit them far, uh,
achieving a significant improvement in the performance.
See, they are the initial contributors
for these architectures.
Conceptually, they can, they were convinced that
these deeper architectures will give better performance,
but when they're training, they're not able to demonstrate.
But of course, there, if it is a stochastic modeling
or some mathematical framework could have been there.
But these are all very non-linear models.
Mathematically explaining is a challenge.
That's where they were unable to explain.
So other, no, the most of the community abundant that,
but the Jeffrey Intern group continued to work along
with the Mac, uh, lean Mac some two more are there.
In 2006, Jeffrey Intern Group, along
with the team of people from his group,
they published a paper showing that how
a deep neural network can be trained,
and that trying deep network provides
the performance, which is significantly better than,
uh, the performance that were achieved
by the classical machine learning algorithm
that was there up to that point.
Okay? And that was no, if you have time,
it is available in his website, neural computation 2006,
a fast learning algorithm for deep belief networks.
You can read it even if you don't understand.
Also, just as a, a good paper, you should read it. Okay?
And, uh, if you,
if you look at the Deep Neur network, again, no,
this is an advanced neur network model, uh, which is, again,
a, even though it is advanced AL network,
but from if you com, com,
if you consider our neuro cognitive model, human brain,
it's a very simplified model of human brain.
Inspired by that, I, I will not say it is, uh, um, you know,
you have learned something from human brain
and trying to, uh, generate a model for that.
It's only inspired by the structure
and functioning of human brain.
It composed of a stack of layers of artificial neurons,
as we'll see in the next part of the lecture.
And, uh, what they demonstrated in 2006 is they demonstrated
that a deeper network can also be trying.
And when we are trying such networks,
that gives significantly better performance compared to
what is achieved by the classical machine learning
methods up to that point.
Whereas training a deeper neur network was widely considered
impossible in nineties,
and most of the researchers had abundant the field, okay?
But with the, it, the, with the, uh, 2006 paper
intern, it gave a rebirth to the field,
and the other group members also independently evaluated
whether it is possible to try that there.
Indeed, they're able to do that,
and that is no, um, uh,
the improvement in the performance was tremendous.
Um, and accordingly, REST is history.
It is from 2006 onwards and snowball effect started,
and, uh, no, uh, a decade later from 2006
to 2016, if you see,
deep learning had conquered the industry,
and today it is at the heart of, uh, any, uh,
much of the magic that is happening in high tech products.
Okay? Whatever we are talking about, charge g, pt
or publicity
or whatever it is that no, uh, what we are enjoying now,
the root seed goes to the 2006 paper publishing.
It is not that he commented on charge GPTR publicity at
that point, as generative model.
He only demonstrated that it is possible to try
and deep neural networks.
Uh, and, uh, once you train them with large amount of data,
they indeed provide significantly better performance.
Okay? So that is what is demonstrated, of course.
See, whe when, when I see this, uh, uh, the deep learning,
when I'm trying to study these, we have
to put them in a proper context.
The, at a broader umbrella, we are talking about the field
of artificial intelligence, which will essentially,
it encompasses all those methods that are developed, uh,
uh, to enable computing machines to mimic
the so-called the intelligent task done by humans
like discovery learning, dealing with uncertainties,
being creative, handling new situations.
These are all intelligent activities done by human humans.
How we can, um, uh,
mimic such activities that means to say, can, um,
a computing machine discover like humans do?
Can machines, computing machines learn like humans do it?
Or can I mimic such abilities?
So that is where the field of ai, of course,
there is other field of ai, which is, uh, in terms
of reasoning, knowledge, representation
by symbols and rules.
There's a very famous, uh, that is called classical ai.
There's an NAL lecture by artificial intelligence processi,
if some of you're interested in the traditional AI you can
look into, but what we are talking about AI now
with this deep learning generative ai, is
it is do deep learning, neural network model based ai, uh,
we call it as connection is ai.
Okay? So if I consider ai,
one of the subfield of the AI is
what is called machine learning, where
you develop capabilities
or mimic trying to mimic the learning capabilities
of humans, um,
on computing machines.
That's why the term machine learning has come into
picture, okay?
That means to say the machine learning will discover
the underlying pattern information from the raw data
without being explicitly said what exactly you have
to learn or how it looks.
Just a simple example is if you consider, no,
there's a very classical, uh, uh, uh, this one,
um, earlier, even
before this AI era, uh, in the email there were up,
there are software which can classify whether the given
email is a spam or in genuine email.
So if it finds its spam, it puts into spam folder.
And if a genuine puts into genuine inbox,
how does people would've done, would've done
by a rule based sort method in the rule based sort method.
Critically, they would've been told no.
Suppose you scan your, uh, incoming email, uh,
as to this program, spam detection program, which go
to the subject line in the subject line.
If these are the words, which are, if you spot any
of these words, you push that into spam folder, okay?
Or in the body you find something like this, some
vocabulary, you push that into spam folder.
That is the simplest rule-based approach we do.
That is to say, in the spam detection program,
I clearly told you, go like this.
Now first you retrieve the field of subject in the subject.
You take this lookup table.
These are the words, if any one
of these words are there in the subject to push that
to the SAP spam folder, you can see now we are step by step,
we are told what to look in the data, okay?
Whereas in the machine learning in the same task, I will,
what machine learning I do is I will say these are all spam,
uh, emails.
These are all, uh, genuine emails,
but I will not tell anything beyond that.
Or spam subject will have, like,
these main body subjects will have like this, nothing.
I will only say these are the set of spam emails,
and these are the inbox, uh, genuine emails.
You'll learn the distinction among these two
and build a machine learning model, which can later,
if I apply randomly any email,
it'll classify correctly into either a spam or an inboxing.
And that is what is machine learning, where a data driven,
learning, data driven learning without being explicitly
programmed on what to look for in that data.
That's why it's called machine learning, like a human
learn from the external world by exploration.
In the same way, machines also will
explore the incoming data.
And in the data driven learning, it'll do a simple thing.
Now, suppose the, the output is a spam or not.
Why output is one or zero.
If it is spam, it is one or it is zero,
and X is the input, uh, email you are putting,
and f is the functional mapping.
Okay? That is this.
F is the machine learning model that you are, uh, building.
That is that machine learning.
Whereas in the d the, the fundamental distinction
between machine learning
and the classical machine learning, let me call it
as classical machine learning versus deep learning, is
in the classical machine learning, we
use the data points.
What we are talking are nothing but features.
And those features are used in the classical machine
learning models for, uh, for doing any
of the machine learning tasks.
Uh, by that I mean, uh, I have
to extract some relevant features
and feed them as data points.
Beyond that, I don't tell how to, what to discover, okay?
Whereas in the deep learning, you don't need to do
that feature extraction.
Also, you can give raw data directly as input
to the deep learning model.
First, in the first few layers,
it'll discover the nonlinear features by itself,
and then use that features further for discovering the,
uh, relationship among the input
and output, which would be used for a machine learning task.
Okay? So a simple distinction
between a classical machine learning models like regression,
uh, support vector machine, shall neur network
versus deep learning model is in case
of classical machine learning.
We use, since the models are very small size, have very two,
three layers like that, they will not have the luxury
to discover themselves.
Uh, the feature that's where raw data first possible
through a feature extraction block to derive the features.
And those features are given us data points for log.
Whereas in the deep learning, uh,
we discover from the raw data model itself will discover
the, uh, features and features
and then passes down to further stages for, uh,
no learning the relationship between the input
and not Okay, pictorial.
If you see traditional machine learning
or classical machine learning
and raw input is there, there's a feature engineering block,
a domain expert will derive and give the features,
and these features are used in classical machine learning
to do any tasks like classification
or something, versus if I go to deep learning,
I take the Ryan put directly, give it
to the deep learning model.
You see now, there are no feature engineering human block
setting there directly apply the deep learning,
and it gives me the classification output.
And that is the D distance
between classical machine learning and deep learning.
And the genesis for deep learning ease.
In terms of the earlier versions, avatars
of this deep learning was neural networks.
Again, these neural networks are inspired by this structure
and functioning of the human brain.
And the basic computing element in the human brain is
biological neuron.
And, uh, the human cognitive power is not just
because of one biological neuron.
There's a massive number of billions
of neurons working in a connect, loosely connected manner
that gives that cognitive power for humans.
And essentially it implies this parallel
and distributed processing.
And, uh, then by observing this from the neuroscience, uh,
people wanted to bring computational models,
which can mimic this parallel
and distributed processing aspect of human cognitive system.
Where in parallel distributed processing network,
we use basic computing elements,
which are called artificial neurons, which are again
inspired by the structure and functioning
of the biological neuron, okay?
And that resulted in the field of
what is called artificial neuron
and the arrangement of them in a ordered manner.
They're called as neural network architectures.
And that whole neural network field was there.
But if you see this neural network,
it gives us a alternative computing model for machine,
classical machine learning.
But their performance in many tasks was not that great
compared to the classical machine learning.
Okay? So as a result of that, no,
even though people started using neural works,
but it is, it did not replace in many machine learning task,
uh, the already successful other
classical machine learning methods.
That's why no people started looking towards,
can I expand this neural network architecture
to have much massive structure?
And that is the motivation for this deep learning.
And that is where no, uh,
if you see the neur networks are deep learning,
it is in terms of the deeper architecture you have.
Only thing was when I increase the number of layers
and the neurons in each layer,
this the work algorithm which was there working
for the SHA neural network, called ba propagation algorithm,
did not work there.
That is where the vanish ingredient problem came into
picture, and that's
where people lost interest in using the deep learning model.
Essentially. Now, uh, looking back now, we are able
to discover how we can train the deep learning model.
Now, the reason that is being attributed for not able
to demonstrate the learning of deep networks in 1990 was
we had very limited data in the,
in any given machine learning task.
Now, because of the connected world,
after 20 years, 20, 30 years, we have large amount of data
for any task, okay?
That was not, uh, available at that point of time.
Accordingly know when you give very limited data
for a deep network, it used to over fit into that data
just memorizes and reproduces.
And we also had difficulty in training.
Uh, no, because even not having great computing power, also,
uh, unable to train the deep learning model earlier,
because insufficient training data,
limited computing power was there at the turn
of the 21st century.
It changed the whole scenario.
Breakthrough in terms of deep training,
deep learning model came algorithmic approach for
demonstrated the capability
for training deep learning model,
and also the methods becomes easy
for collecting data from the world.
Connected world. And large computing power came at the
disposal due to, so all these things, algorithm development,
easy of data collection,
and good computing power in terms of GPU
for processing parallel and distributed data, okay?
If you see pictorially, if you want to see machine,
classical machine learning versus deep learning, uh,
the raw data, I do feature engineering here,
only features are given to the input layer of the, uh,
classical machine learning method.
But in the deep learning, there is no feature engineering.
I explained earlier, raw input is given
to the deep learning mode.
In the end, if you want to give a big picture of
what are all that is developed in the connectionist,
in the AI field, AI is the big circle within that.
The major portion is what we are talking about,
the machine learning, classical, uh, machine learning,
which includes both classical as well
as deep learning and generative ai.
And, uh, one subset
of machine learning is the neural network.
The improved versions of the advanced version
of the neur networks resulted in deep learning.
And the further generative versions
of the deep learning models subset became
generative AI models.
That is how the trajectory you can trace
from the initial AI
to the current generation generative AI models
that you are talking about.
So this is the journey that has, uh, taken place,
uh, in the field so far.
And that is what you are going to have a, you know, study
as a part of your mtech courses.
I'll stop it here. Uh, maybe if you have any questions
or something, uh, kindly let me know.
Any of you, if you have any.
Yeah. So what is main neural network
and, uh, deep neur neural network.
So deep learning.
So, so is the size, uh, only, uh, the size of, uh,
only the difference
or some more difference are there between deep learning
and neural networks?
Look, and field wise, the size, okay. Yes.
But, uh, the internal wise, uh, capability
to ingest large amount of data, okay?
Suppose if I have billions of data points, if you go
for giving to conventional network, they cannot do anything.
It is, no, for example, the, the what we call, um,
digestive capability of a person can consume only one chap,
and you make, give 10 chaps, he will not be able to consume
because his, his capability is only to eat one chap.
Yes. Even now you are making it available 10 chapatis,
he will not be able to do anything.
And whereas in the deep, if he's a very gym going person,
no colleague like fellow, so he can eat 10 chapatis also.
That is what is the deep learning
model we are talking about.
Thank you. Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Any other questions?
Um, I had one question. Who is this,
Sir? Ruby?
Oh, the role number,
Ruby, how are you?
Oh, sir. Going on. Don't ask me.
I wanted to talk to you. Yes, sir. I think it was good.
I mean, respect to the marks,
but I, sir, one thing is we don't know relatively
how we stand when we get the marks.
We'll see, we'll see. Don't Worry. Okay. Okay. Anyway,
You have to worry about marks and rates.
That is true, sir. So I mean, this kindled the college,
uh, 20, I don't know, 25 years back, you know,
where we used to be worried about our status.
You know, our status used to be a rank in the class. Okay?
Anyway, sir. Um, how much deep is the mathematics here, sir?
And how much serious should we be?
Uh, so when we read these research papers, for example,
there's some notations which are very challenging in terms
of the mathematics, the Nala and all that. Yeah.
I'll request Dr. Sunil to comment and then I'll come.
Okay, sir. So yes,
I see, uh, uh, that, uh, we want to make the connect
because, uh, the way we want to deliver this particular, uh,
uh, courses, we want to make it 50 50 in the sense
that 50 would be 30 and 50 would be hands-on uhhuh.
Now, in the 50 also theory part, which I have said,
it'll be like 25, or I would say 30
or 35 will be conceptual explanation,
but minimum 10 to 50% would be the
mathematics which has to come.
Then only you will be able to connect the things.
Yes, sir. So we are not afraid, I'm just asking you. Yeah.
Okay. So this is the way we,
which we want to, uh, go ahead.
And what I see that mathematics part majorly,
it'll be a vectors, multiplication, additions.
And when it comes to the back prop,
because that is what we have in the forward
of the neural network, forward propagation
of the neural network and the back propagation,
we have this gradient calculation
or chain rule of the calculus.
Hmm. These two are the many
whatever networks you are going to see,
Right? You
are going to see these two maths, which is there.
That's all nothing else,
Right? And sir,
uh, one suggestion, or one,
because I mean,
we almost had a heart attack when we saw your assignment.
Okay? And then we could not recover,
and then we had the final exam.
Okay? So, uh, we request,
and for maths also,
we did get a heart attack when the first assignment came,
but then we recovered because we had some time.
So, sir, especially to you,
one request is please give us daily problems, sir,
which we have to, you know, write in a notebook
or, you know, maybe a program, uh,
because sir, uh, we being, uh, professionals, we get sucked.
See, sir, working is our comfort zone.
We know what to do, so we gravitate towards
working rather than studying.
Studying takes effort. So if you could give us
that discipline, sir, um, maybe, uh,
two weeks you can let us be.
And then from the third week onwards, please give us daily,
or every, every class give us a small as assessment, sir.
So brains also need some time to tune.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
We are also planning in the same way. Let us see.
Okay. Even you don't grade it. Okay.
I mean, we don't, I mean, the thing is we want
to get the pen and paper, uh, practice, uh,
before we get heart attacks.
Mm-hmm. So that's the thing, sir.
Yeah. We'll, we'll do that. We'll do that.
See more, more, uh, Ruby, what we are thinking is,
uh, see, you need to be, all
of you should become more comfortable with, uh, know,
working with at least one versatile
open source toolkit like arch.
Yeah. That is the, I will say, yeah, that is the, uh,
50% of your requirement.
And, uh, maybe another 30% is in terms
of knowing the working principles
of different ative learning models that we're gonna discuss.
Remaining 20% is some mathematics
to explain the concepts not beyond, uh, that,
that is the way we are going to think.
Because in a working domain, what you require is
if you're able to say, you know,
I have comfortable working relationship with toolkit,
I can implement and demonstrate
that is most required from a working professional.
Mm. That is what we're 50%
of our effort will go in that direction.
And another 30% district explain the working principles,
Right? And
When you explain working principles,
if there is an equation required,
minimum mathematical equation, we use it to help it better,
Right? Sir? Another
thing is, you know,
the deployment concepts, sir.
So we could write programs, but then you know how to deploy.
I mean, when the data is coming in real time, right?
Every day, so you have a data ingestion
or, you know, things like that.
How do you, how does the model learn?
And, you know, how do you, um,
keep publishing the ROC curve?
And, you know, those kind of things were there
for traditional ml, but I don't know here.
So sir, some, uh, I mean,
at least we should be aware of that.
Maybe some reading links or, you know, uh,
unless it's there in the syllabus,
we don't write, sir, that's the,
In the advance topics or something.
We'll try to, yeah,
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, sir. Thank you. Thank you very much, sir. Thank
You. Thank you. All the best.
Thank you, sir. Karthik has the,
Hi, sir, are you sir?
Good evening. Thank fine.
Uh, sir, uh, just a question in this like, um, this, uh,
the state planning, it'll be a bit similar to like MLP where
we, the sir used to give demonstration
and then we, we used to do the programs by ourself,
or do you want us to lively do
how we are doing in the, uh, class?
So, uh, after the three sections,
what the main practical things
and then how it'll be, it'll be like demo and then
after the class we do, or we do it live with you.
Mostly it'll be like that demo because mm-hmm.
Uh, there is a reason behind it.
If you do live, that's not a problem.
But the only point is, I mean, all
of us have to think, right?
Yeah. Obviously, uh, some of them, uh,
may do it a little faster.
Some of us may take some our own time, right?
And then one and a half hour we'll go,
maybe we'll not be able to cover the topic.
So that, that is the main reason.
That's why first we demonstrate
and we give the same notebook to you.
Change that, build other model, use some other data set,
do the practice by yourself,
come back and ask the questions.
I guess that with the right model,
because everyone needs their own time to say, to write
and to see, okay, what is happening inside.
Uh, so that is, I see the better, better idea to go. Yeah, I
Agree, sir.
I agree with yes, yes.
So it'll be more similarly how we had in MLP. Yes.
Yeah, yeah. Mostly. Yeah. Okay, sir. Thank you.
Thank you. Yeah.
We'll go to the next module.
Yes. So I, I'll present sir, then. Yeah, yeah,
Please, please. Okay.
Alright. So, uh, the plan is, uh, that
before starting with more theory, uh,
although I had given you some exposure
of the neural network in the machine learning, uh, uh,
paradigm scores, MLP, that what exactly is the neuron,
how does it work and all,
but we are going to revise that concept in this course
as well, just to refresh that, what we had covered,
because that would be the foundation for the deep learning.
But even, uh, before we dive into that,
which we'll do in the next class, I want
to introduce the toolkit
or the framework library, which we are going
to use in this particular course for our hands-on.
Now, that is most important
because as we set 50 50, we are going
to cover this hands-on along with the concept and mapping.
So, uh, pythons is the library, which we are going to use,
because that is one of the most, uh, uh, you can say the,
uh, famous as well as usable library
for the deep learning, right?
So we are going to use the same,
we also have alo alongside the PyTorch.
We have this, uh, tensor flow,
and then these two are the one which compete
with e each other, I understand.
But then, uh, in the academic setting, research, uh,
research setting, as well as, uh,
even in the industry setting nowadays,
PyTorch has gained more popularity over the
TensorFlow, right?
So, uh, that's the reason even we thought that, okay,
PyTorch is the right, uh, library, uh, which with,
with which we'll start.
So today, I'm going to start with that.
We'll give you some, some history about this PyTorch,
and if possible, I'll also show you some, some,
some very basics, uh, of the PyTorch, what
and all we can do, right?
And, uh, I mean, uh, like what the most
of the things you must have covered in the Python, uh,
I mean data science lab or the last course, MLP,
but then from the angle,
how the same thing we can implement, say that the
ARI concept, the dimension concept,
and all that in the, in the, uh, in the hands-on.
I will show you that one. If time covers, uh, we will cover
that today, but otherwise, I'll continue
that in the next class.
So, uh, to start with, uh, this, this is, uh, I mean, most
of the books are here, same,
but then the, the second last, what you can see, I mean,
most all of you can, uh, uh,
use this one hands-on machine learning using Psyche Learn
KRAS and TensorFlow here.
Uh, this might be helpful not for the PyTorch,
but then for the hands-on perspective
of whatever we are going to cover.
So, uh, you can, you can see this particular book.
This is really good, and based given the concept how
to implement this book has given quite well,
and I guess it's earlier editions are
available online as well.
So I'll share this, uh, slide with you,
and then you can just type this one in the Google, uh,
and you will get this book.
You can use this book for your own practice. Okay?
To start with, uh, about the PyTorch, uh,
like we have used psychic Learn in the case
of machine learning, or I showed you the kras, uh, in some
of the cases, uh, PyTorch is one in the, on the same line.
PyTorch is one of the library, and it is majorly
for the deep learning, not
for the conventional machine learning.
Also, it is majorly for the Deeplearning,
and it was developed by, uh, Facebook
or Meta, you can say that.
Then it was known as Facebook, uh, AI research The Fair,
this is the team who have developed this by Torch, which is
initially, uh, started for the research,
and then slowly it is also into, in,
into the production, right?
And it is famous due to its dynamic computation gives
with the, uh, gives you multiple flexibility to,
to change the network dynamically however you want.
And most importantly, it keeps you with the feeling
of Python, right?
Python. When I say Python, uh, you may say that, okay,
when transfer flow is a Python, what do you mean
by Python feeling?
It means that in the Python, why the Python, uh, is
so famous, and, uh, like, uh, people, uh, say
that it is quite easy to use
because it looks like a natural language.
Like in English, we are typing and we are reading,
and we can understand, right?
So the s has kept that design
and feeling that, okay, you're still using the Python,
but then on top of that, it has come up with lot
of capabilities, right?
So that's, that's how the PY au came into the picture.
And if you talk about the history of the PyTorch,
how this team has developed this PyTorch, it is inspired
by the Torturer library, which was initially given in 2002
by Idea Research Institute at
EPFL in Switzerland.
This was the first try, uh, uh, which, uh, people have given
for the deep learning
or neural networks library, you can say.
Then, so in 2002, and,
and it was known as Torch that time, it was not a PyTorch,
but that time it was known as Torch.
Why it was not a PyTorch,
because, uh, it was, uh,
it was initially given
for the programming language called Lua.
It was not, uh, it was not written in the Python, okay?
So people who have the group
who have given this torch library, they have, uh, written
all the code, either Lua programming,
obviously the Torch has the capability, uh, it,
it showed the capability to work with the tens,
which I'll talk in brief in the coming, uh,
slides, as well as with the demo.
And it also shows the capability to work with the GPU,
although the GPU was very rare, uh, that, uh, that time,
but then it showed the capability to work
with the GPU and the neural networks.
So that was the capability of the tos.
Now, when this GPU, uh, means the resource,
which was the initial problem with the neural network
and took time, uh, to, uh, to, to, uh, to, uh,
gain its popularity, what we are seeing, uh, now.
So when we started get, uh, uh, getting those
resources available, at least with the big giants, with,
with companies and big research institutes now, uh, the,
the Facebook, the meta team, the fair team,
I would say they, they saw the capability of the torch that
how it can easily work with the tensor and the GPU.
And they also saw that the, the simplicity
of the Python, right?
And that is how they plan to mix these two, the Python
and the torch, and that's
how they have given a library called as Python, right?
So that's how, this is the story.
I, I guess, uh, I thought that I will give you this, uh, uh,
this, uh, brief story that you, okay, you would be knowing
that, okay, how the people realize that, okay, this, uh,
library is, is going to be the break breakthrough
and people, it's going to be one
of the most popular already in the future.
So as, as you can see, the is built on top
of the original Torch library.
I just in 2002.
And, uh, uh, it was re-engineered, you can say
by the fair team, the Facebook AI research team,
and that's how they have even the, despite torch,
which is good with, good with the review acceleration,
we talk about in the coming classes, what is this auto grad,
uh, we'll talk about the flexible API, all these things.
We'll talk torch, uh, we'll talk in terms of the PyTorch
and how you can take it, uh, take the PyTorch, uh, in the,
in the production as well, not only with the research
and all may.
Uh, so all these things are possible with the s.
Now, uh, this was the initial story that how, okay,
how exactly the PyTorch was given,
but then once it was released from then on means from
2017 onwards, we have multiple versions
of the PyTorch, which are, which has been, uh, proposed.
So in the 2016, 17, that was the initial version, right?
And then in 18, uh, it was not even the version one,
it was version 0.1 when it was initially released,
but in the 2018, the first version of the PyTorch was given,
and it, when it became the more stable
and it was little production ready,
and that's when the, there are two things which was given
by the PyTorch, uh, the, the Facebook meta
that is called torch script
and ONNX, uh, support so that it can be, uh, uh,
converted the model, what you're developing,
deep learning model, you, what you're developing can,
can is, is production ready, okay?
So that, that's how it's, so then in 2019, 21
more stable ecosystem was, uh, proposed where
different libraries in the PyTorch itself, for example,
if you're doing the vision problem,
then we have the torch vision.
If you're doing the text related problem,
you have the torch text, audio related problem,
then you have torch audio.
So all those ecosystem were proposed,
proposed within the PyTorch, then into 2023.
The 2.2, uh, the pie towards 2.2 was proposed here.
They introduced the stores.com by now.
This was one of the important, uh, like, uh, uh,
contribution in this particular version.
They improved on the graph optimization and major speedups.
We'll talk more on that when we'll code these things.
Uh, and I'll show you the hands on.
And finally from the 24, 25 when we are in there,
they are still continuing
and evolving this particular library with various,
various features, right?
So this was the different, uh, uh, timeline, uh, uh,
timeline about the PyTorch.
If I talk about a little bit about the core features
of the PyTorch, these are some of the core features,
like they have the dynamic computational computation graph.
Uh, but I said that, right? It's very flexible.
Then when you will write the code, you will, uh,
we will, we'll see that one.
It's very easy to build and modify the net network.
So it's dynamically you can change your code, right?
The most important, or you can say the core, core part
of the PyTorch was the tensor, okay?
Tensor operations with GPU support.
Now, this is very important, right?
Uh, because this is, this is the realization the team had,
and that's how they have given
and if, if, if not pythons, you can understand this
with the more, with the tensor flow,
which was came just when, year back in 2015, right?
Uh, when the name of the library was given
as tensor flow on the name of the tensor itself.
So tensor is very important to the deep learning.
So, uh, and this PyTorch was very good with the tensors.
So all the kind of operations with the tensors
and how the tensors can be, can utilize the GPU support.
It is really good with that. We'll see that one.
So this sensors are nothing but like, it, it looks, look
and feel is like a MPA area,
but then you can work with the higher dimens sensor, also
with the tensor, which was the need of the, uh,
unstructured data, uh, data.
What we have, then we'll see that, uh, in the pythons,
we have the support of the auto grad,
because in the neural network when we build,
we have the forward propagation,
and we have the backward propagation.
So the forward propagation will be doing this operations,
sensors, operations like WX plus B,
because wait inputs get multiplied, add the bias, followed
by the activation function.
We'll talk about that. And, uh,
when we do the back propagation, then it's all about
how you are updating those weights using the gradients.
And that's where this partial
differentiations come into the picture.
This, uh, this chain room come into the picture.
And this auto grad module of this is very important.
And without, without any hustle, you will see
that you write the code
and it's, it'll do the, all the gradient calculation,
it'll do the updates, right?
So all those things that will do so easily.
So this auto grad is very important.
We'll take maybe will spend one, one lecture, uh,
if not completely, but half, half lecture
to understand this auto grad component of the PyTorch.
Then we have in the au this neural network module, okay?
To build the model, uh, itself, that if you want
to build fully connected layer,
RNN recurrent neural network, CNN conation neural network,
we can use the storage NN module in the PyTorch,
and we will build our models.
We can add the biases into, into this.
We can, we can decide to add activation functions.
We can calculate the loss.
All these things can be done with this module.
We have the optimizer modules module here in the
PyTorch, right?
Which will take care of the, all the optimization,
like a stochastic gradient descent
or Adam RMS prop, which are very popular with the,
uh, deep neural networks.
We also have the data set utilities, like you can,
you have the data set and data data loader module,
which handle, uh, quite well that, okay?
How you want to feed the data to the network,
how, how you can load the data.
First of all, how you can divide your data into the patches
and how you can feed it
to the neural network for the training.
All those things we'll see in this particular module.
And as I said, it has the strong ecosystem
for different kind of data.
Like if you are working with the vision, data, text data,
audio, data oriented, other special kind of tasks as well.
So these are some of the, um, uh, important, uh, features
of the PyTorch, which we are going to use right now.
Uh, I thought that, I'll give you one slide just
to make a difference between PyTorch and sensor flow.
Both are, uh, both are popular, uh, I would say,
but initially, uh, the way they were proposed,
they had the different objective.
But then, now, now, I would say that PyTorch has the
more popularity in term as compared to the tensor flow,
but that was not the initial initial case.
So based on these aspects, uh, here are some differentiation
between the PyTorch and tensor flow.
If you see the execution style, uh, I mean now,
now both are same.
Initially the tensor flow was a static.
They were creating the static route,
but now they also have the dynamic creation and all.
So both are almost at the same level.
If you talk about the ease of use, Python is easy
as compared to the tensor flow,
and that's why it is more popular, also
because it is more ic, as I talked earlier,
and it more intuitive.
But then tensor flow is little bit
complex when you will start, uh,
at the beginner level, right?
So it is more structured.
You have to follow a particular structure
to write the code in the tensor flow.
Once you know that one, then that also becomes easy.
But to start with, if you'll see that PyTorch has, uh,
is more easy as compared to the tensor flow.
Uh, debu debugging strategy is easy in the PyTorch
as compared to the TensorFlow research research adoption.
PyTorch is dominating in the research domain, at least
as compared to the TensorFlow production tool.
Three, TensorFlow has always upper hand in the
production tools, okay?
Now also you can see if you talk only in the production,
now TensorFlow is, is better than the PyTorch,
although PyTorch has done lot of improvement.
But then TensorFlow was initially meant
for converting the deep learning models into the production
rather than just building in the, yeah.
So that was the, that is the difference in TensorFlow,
I would say that will win if we talk
about the production tool.
Now, ecosystem wise.
Now, uh, NRU, TensorFlow has good ecosystem for any kind
of data, whatever you will use
and hardware support, both of them are supporting this, uh,
hardware, like G-P-U-T-P-U and all that.
That's not a problem nowadays.
So this is where they match the, where,
which one is more preferable, uh, as compared to others.
So if you see, uh, when to use what, so PyTorch,
if you're doing mostly the research experimentations,
the academic works nowadays, even in the production, uh,
but less as compared to the transfer.
Uh, TensorFlow, TORS is more popular,
and TensorFlow is more about the production,
more about the deployment, like mobile apps, TPUs,
largest skills, uh, serving.
So all these things are the, the, uh, you can say that the
benefits of the tensor flow.
So this is how they, these two are like competing.
Obviously, you must be knowing that tensor flow is given
by the Google, and, uh, by is by the meta.
That is how these two players are, uh,
like competing with each other.
Now, today, I just wanted to see that,
okay, which one is more popular?
So I just went to the google.trends.com,
and I have taken this, uh, this, this, uh, uh,
figure what you're seeing today itself.
So that how this TensorFlow
and PyTorch, which one is more popular and all.
So this is the Google trend, who, which is telling
and creating the dis difference between TensorFlow
and, uh, PyTorch.
You see that initial, so I have taken the
last five years data.
So today, now we are in 20 20, 20 25.
And from 2020, this is, okay.
So, uh, you see that initially, uh, at, at this point
of time in 2020, almost, they had the same kind of
before this one, if I, I would've gone,
maybe the TensorFlow would have more popular as compared
to the s because, uh,
TensorFlow was the one which people were using in the
industry for the deployment and the production, right?
But then slowly in, uh, during the 2020s,
they were at the same pace.
But after this particular time, you can see that this red,
okay, uh, a red curve, it is, it is always growing up.
And now when we are in 2025, it has taken more popularity.
You can see that this is the trend.
You can also go to the google.trend.com,
and you can compare these two, uh, uh, these two.
How it has it has come. Okay?
So this is just one visualization I wanted to give.
Now, uh, I, I,
although we will talk more about these modules one by one,
when we'll go into the depth of the, uh, PyTorch,
but these are some of the modules which we are going
to learn, like we will talk about the torch, uh,
once we import the torch,
what are the different functionality we can do
with the PyTorch?
Like we can do the math, fun functions.
We can do some random utilities and all torch taught,
and then I talked about to building the sequential models
and all we can use or, uh, any kind of neural network.
We'll use the storage. NN this is for the optimization.
This is for the auto grad, which I talked about
for the back propagation
and, uh, uh, for data, how you are managing dataset,
data set, data loader, batching,
shuffling, transforms, all those things.
We'll use this torch util store data,
and we have the different ecosystem for the torch vision,
text and audio.
So this will talk anyway, slowly.
We are, we are good to talk.
Now, if you would be curious that, okay, uh,
princip flow is good, then, uh, by Google, then
who is using the PyTorch at,
at TensorFlow means Google is using the TensorFlow.
Obviously, Google is not using the PyTorch, uh, obviously,
but then who is using the PyTorch?
You can see that meta, they have given this PyTorch.
So they are using all their
AI based deep learning based model.
Whatever they're proposing, they're
using the PyTorch for that.
Microsoft, they're using the PyTorch, uh, their Tesla,
then open ai, nvidia, all of them are making use
of the PyTorch for building different, different, uh, these,
uh, deep learning models, large language models,
then AI models, whatever you will say.
So they, they are all the, then many other companies.
Also, I have taken some, most trans five companies
who are using this Pipers.
Yeah, this was one, uh, slide.
I wanted to, I'll upload this slide for your, uh,
this.
Now I have, uh, another slide
where I'd go into the more, uh,
you would say the details of the tensors,
because this is the first thing what you have
to understand in the pythons, right?
Because pythons is built, uh, as the name suggest,
it's a python and tensors, it's a marriage
between the Python and the tensors.
And, uh, that's how this pys library was proposed.
So understanding the tensors in detail,
in depth is very important.
Okay? So now let's see that how to, uh, uh, you, uh,
how to, what, what are the, uh, things in the tens.
Now, if I talk about the tens tensors, uh, are,
uh, are the fundamental data structure,
like you can talk about the array, right?
Array, the data structure where, uh,
or listed the data structure in Python.
Mm. Uh, uh, you can see the dictionary,
the data structure in Python.
So likewise, tensor is also a data structure in Python.
So data structure, what is the role?
You can store the data and, uh, so for the,
and you can face the data for whatever uses you want.
So tensor is also used for that.
So if you want to store the data,
or you want to use the data for some purpose,
some operation, you can use the tensors now, then you, uh,
so, uh, uh, so the tens tensors, why,
why it became, uh, you, you may argue that, okay, why,
why then tensors, why not, uh, Ari?
Okay? Because if it is same, then why not add? So, uh, fine.
When, when you talk about the one dimension, two dimension,
tens would look like a re
and, uh, not only look, it'll also behave like an ari.
Whenever you do any kind of operations
with those sensors, it is nothing.
But, uh, you are doing the operations
with an array or list, okay?
Mostly, but tens are good when you go to the end dimension.
Now, that was the most important, right?
In the case of the deep learning dimensions
are very important, right?
Because you must have heard right that, uh, that embeddings,
uh, say that, uh, this,
this GPT has the input dimensions in 2 0 4 8.
Now this dimension is so huge, okay? It's two so huge.
So tens are good with the end dimensions.
No, A is good with the one dimension,
two dimension, three dimension.
You can say that, right? But when it go
to the four dimension, when it go to the five dimension,
how does it look like?
How do they process?
And with the tensors, one more, uh, uh,
one more advantage is it can
utilize the GPU capability, okay?
It can utilize the GPU capability, which, which, which, uh,
you can't do with the area again.
So that, that's, that there are some, uh, uh,
you can say the differences as compared to the
and tensiles based on their uses and the capability.
And that's why tensiles people have, uh, opted
for the steep learning task.
So tensiles are the fundamental data structure in PyTorch,
and they are generalization of scalers vectors, mattresses,
and even to the higher dimension.
For example, uh, we can represent scaler
as a tensor, and that would we say as a rank zero tensor.
If you have the one dimensional array, you can say
that rank one tensor.
If you have a matrix, you can say
that it's the two dimensional tens,
or you can also have the three dimensional, um, you can say
that will say rank three tens.
Now, to understand it a little better, I don't know
how to remove this.
Uh, clear, clear or try, yeah, fine, thank you.
So, uh, you see this, so we have the, uh,
zero dimensional tensors, right?
We say zero D tensors, and these zero D tens are nothing
but a scalers you can rep.
So now, instead of using,
or instead of saying the term as array, uh,
we will be using in the deep learning,
we'll be using the term tensors, and we'll see why
and why it is helpful in the end dimension.
So now let us see that how we can represent the, uh,
tensors in the different dimensions.
So if it is a zero dimension, it is nothing,
but the scaler means
that it is not a spread in any direction, right?
It is just one value, like a scaler,
like 3.14 is just a value,
or 5.0 is just a value.
Now, in the deep learning, there are multiple places.
You know, that, that where we use a scaler, we, we, we,
we will be using the scaler, for example,
when we have the neural network,
we do the forward preparation
and we compare the prediction of the model
with the target value, we calculate the loss.
So that loss is always a scaler value.
That loss is always a scaler value.
So how do we represent that?
We'll represent it using the zero d tens,
zero dimensional tensor, we'll represent it.
Or sometimes, uh, in the ation where we have the update rule
where we update the weights, for example, weights,
musical two weights, old minus
learning rate into gradient, right?
So that, that there also,
the learning rate is a skill value.
We represent it using the tensors.
Similarly, in the multiple places, we'll see that, uh,
even in the going, going forward,
when you will talk about this, um, uh,
you will talk about the self attention.
We'll see that how to, uh,
how the self attention concept use this scalers,
where it gets multiplied with the 1D tensor.
So there are multiple places in the deep learning of,
we will see that we are going, we are making use
of these zero dimensional tens.
Now, if you talk about one dimensional tens, it is nothing
but a 1D, RA if in a, in a single word.
So many places. Again, you are going to use
of this one dimensional for mostly in the case
of the word embeddings, which is very famous.
In the larger language models
or language models, embeddings are represented as one time,
uh, uh, means, uh, you can say that 1D tens, where, uh,
you can see that the, it's a flat vector
where you have multiple dimension column wise.
Row wise, you have a single area,
you have a single, single row.
So that is called one dimensional vector, for example.
This is, this is one, one dimensional vector.
So you can represent a, uh, a word into this,
this one dimensional tens,
or you can represent, represent whole sentence also
as one dimensional tensors in the, in the deep learning.
We'll see that going further.
How to represent the sentences or word
or character as a one dimensional tens.
Now two dimensional tens, obviously it is,
it is something which is spread in two directions.
So here spread in the sense.
You can say that if, if you talk about this one.
So it has a spread only in this particular direction, right?
Uh, so there is, there is only one direction to to,
to this one now,
but, uh, uh, when, when you go
to the, oh, okay.
So, uh, when you go to the two dimensional tensor,
now you have the spread into two different directions.
So when I say two different directions, it means
that you can grow in this direction.
Also. You, you have the, this direction,
there are two different directions mostly used
for the image dataset in the deep learning.
We'll go whenever you have to read,
the image will utilize this two dimensional tens,
for example, and mostly for the gray scale
image, the black and white image.
It is like administrator set where you have the, uh, uh,
is it one to represent.
You can rep represent the is one, like, like that.
Uh, it should have been like this also.
But then say that this is the number one, which,
which is being represented.
And this here, uh, because it is a black and white image
or gray skin image, we say it better.
We need two different dimension Here.
We have, we say that usually the ated dataset, uh,
which we have I guess used for the MLP class, also
for the demo demo purpose, it is OP 28, cross 28 pixel.
That means that we have 28 values here, RO wise
and 28 values here, column wise, also like this,
that is the meaning of it.
So this, you can represent using the 2D tens.
Now,
uh, uh, one second.
Oh, this one.
Okay. So, uh, now sir,
One quick question.
Yeah, please, amne, any digit would be, uh, uh,
would be a 2D metrics, right? 2D answer,
Yes. Because it is gray
scale, uh, not only ams uhhuh,
any image which are gray skill will be 2D uhhuh.
So when, uh, r GV comes,
then it becomes those many dimensions
More, correct? Correct.
Correct. Okay. Yeah.
That itself is the next, is the when,
when the 3D sensors would be utilized.
So it's an image only,
but you have three different channels.
So the first one represent, okay,
how many channels you have,
and the second dimension represent here, the, okay,
what is the height, and then what is the width?
Okay? So there are three dimensions in which it is a spread.
So you will use the 3D tens, okay?
So any, any colored image will be the, the, we will,
we are going to represent
that one using 3D tensors, okay?
Similarly, we have the four D tensors also.
Uh, now suppose you want to process the image in a batch.
Now you can utilize this for now, this, that.
Now from here onwards, you can see the difference, which
usually it is difficult
with when you will work with the arrays.
So, uh, now feeding, creating the batch in the array
and feeding it to the model, uh, uh,
and then using the GPU capabilities is difficult.
But then with the 10 cells, these things becomes quite easy.
Now with the four dimension array,
now suppose you have the image
and you are training your neural network
with a convolution neural network, you want to
feed the 10 image at a time.
So bedside would be 10. Here I'm showing 32.
That means 32 images are being fed in a batch, right?
And then all 32, you can process badly, you know, that,
that, that would be the GPU capability, obviously.
And then the rest three dimensions are seen, like
what we have seen for the 3D dimensions.
The first one would be that, okay, it say
that there are three channels.
That means that it is a colored image,
and the, the, uh, image size is 2 4 24 across 2 24.
So that is how you can represent the four D tensors.
And in the four D tensor, these are the values
with which would be stored similarly, you can extend it
for the five D tensors.
Now, say that instead of image
or batch image, you have the video
and you have the video clip.
Now you have 10 seconds video,
and that 10 seconds video, uh, you can say
that you have five frames.
Just say that. Okay? So, uh, the five frames
and e uh, each five frames are frames are
nothing but the image, right?
That each frames having the, the RGB means three channels.
So you have the five as a frames,
which you are processing together,
because that is the best size of one clip of the video.
And then three channels, 1 28 across 1 10 28 is the, is the,
you can say the MS size
or, uh, uh, that is the frame size, right?
And what is this two? The two is representing,
we have two such clips.
Now, so far, we were able to process,
say the 32 frames together.
But now if you would say no, now I'm dealing with the video,
I have the clips, so I want to process two clips together.
Now, how can you do that? Four d tensor cannot do that one.
So then you would require the five D tensors,
which here is representing the first, uh, uh, it's,
it's something like a time domain.
You can say that, right?
Uh, is a two videos each having the five frames,
three channels, so R, G, B, okay, and then 1 28 across 1 28.
See the frame sites. So all these things I want to embed,
embed A in, in, in as, as a data,
and that's where I would require the five D tens.
Now, likewise, you can keep on extending,
you can even use the 60 tensor, 70 tensor D tensors.
And that is what is the flexibility this
and, uh, this particular tensors gives you,
and that's why tensors are, uh,
being used in the deep learning
because that is what we want also, right?
Because in, in, when we talk about this, uh, deep learning
and this large language model, we don't know that what kind
of data, what forms of data
and worst dimension we are going to receive,
and we, uh, we should be in a po uh, position
to process everything, right?
So that, that's where these sensors are quite helpful.
Uh, we have another five minutes, four minutes.
I would conclude with 1, 1, 1 or two slide actual demo,
although I'll, I'll, I'll, uh,
share the, the slide with you.
You see that here, there is a demo link.
I'll share this one. You can start practicing by yourself.
Next class, I'll quickly go through it, uh,
and you all, uh, to, to explain you
what are the important parts of that demo.
Fine, but
before we'll conclude, uh, uh,
why these tensors are useful in deep learning.
So there are three, uh, uh,
three things which I have mentioned here,
the mathematical operations, which is quite easy
and quite fast because of the GPU.
So mathematical operations are quite easy
with the tens representation of real world data is easy,
like I was talking about 2D, 3D, four D, five D,
and I have told you what these Ds
or dimensions are representing.
So your real world data will be in the form of image,
audio, text, video.
Now, these are the complex data which we deal
in day-to-day life, right?
And that also you can encode with these sensors,
and that's why tensors are being useful in the deep learning
and it can make use of the GPUs and dpu obviously.
So when I talk about this mathematical operations,
I have already told you, although
that in the neural network,
when you do the forward propagation, you have to do,
you have to multiply and put with the weights, right?
So there the mathematical operation
and many other mathematical operations will see going
forward, which we have to do, right?
And similarly representation I was talking about, right?
You can represent each word as an embedding.
So those are the types of, uh, those are the situations
where will will utilize
to represent the data using the tensors
and GPU capabilities.
Also, we have talked about, so in the data stories,
whether you talk about the data stories,
we utilize the tensor, you talk about the weights
and biases, we'll utilize the tensors
because these are all the metricses
and any kind of metrics operation,
which will utilize the tensors forward propagation
of any kind of neural network which utilize the tensors,
backward propagation, radiant calculations and all.
We'll utilize the tens. So everywhere there
is a tensors, right?
Wherever you will see, um, in this, uh, whole pipeline
of the deep learning that there is an input tensor being fed
to the neural network, you calculate this W into X plus B
tensor calculation model prediction.
You do, you calculate the loss tensor
because that is a zero D tensor back propagation gradient
calculation is a tensor ablation of the weight.
So everywhere there is a tensors, okay?
In that whole deep learning whatever you're going.
So, uh, although I'm not going to start this last slide
for today, but these are all the things which we'll see in
the demo link that we will first try to understand how
to create these tensors in the PyTorch.
We'll then try to work with the shapes, how to, uh, get
to know what is the shape, how to, uh, change the shapes
and all, how to get to know what are the data type
of the tens, how to change that whenever it is required.
What are the different mathematical operations
we can do with the tensors?
How to create, how to copy a tensor in the another tensors.
We'll also see if we, if the tensor utilizes CPU
for a particular operation, say metrics,
multiplication, how much time it takes.
And we also do the same operation with the GPU.
I'll show you how much time it takes so
that you will realize that the capability of the tensors,
so all those things are there in this demo link.
So if you will click, uh, you, it'll lead, it lead
to you the collab notebook.
All of you are familiar with the collab notebook,
so I don't have to start with, you can start just, uh,
practicing this one.
Okay? Uh, sorry, this is not that one,
but I'll, I'll, I have created, this is the mother link.
I just have to copy that. Okay, no problem.
So this is the link I was talking about 10 in the,
I'll replace the link in that, uh,
and you can start using that one.
And if there is any confusion in the next class,
when I'll start, I'll start with this notebook itself,
and then I'll quickly go through that one
and then we'll move on to the next part of the PyTorch.
So I'll stop here for your quick questions
and uh, maybe then we'll move on to the
next class when we will start with the first, uh, first uh,
concept in the deep learning, a neural network
and side by side we'll use this PyTorch
to code that as well.
Uh, sir, good evening. Good evening.
Uh, sir, summary, you said, uh, TensorFlow is better for,
uh, production deployment, uh, compared to PyTorch.
So what exactly is that? Uh, production, uh, you mean
Means once, suppose you have built, built the, uh, model,
say that it is working in your collab notebook, okay, say
that machine translation is one such application,
which you are, are building now, how you will convert
that model into the app so that
end user will start using it.
That is what they have done, right? Okay.
That all the, all the applications, what we are using
as an end user that is in the production, that we are able
to use it now, that is, uh, the TensorFlow has, uh,
has a good hold on that they, whatever they have the modules
for the production ready deployment
and all now that are, that, that was better
and comparable as compared to the tors.
Now, at this point of time, I would say, yeah,
Okay, thank you sir.
But you, you said, uh, uh, the usage of, uh, tensor flow
and, uh, PyTorch over the years.
Correct? So PyTorch has taken, uh,
a lead over tensor flow.
So whether tensor flow will be there in the, in the foray
or will it become obsolete, uh, over the years?
See, tensor flow is given by I also mentioned by Google.
Okay? And Google is, uh, Google is not going
to use PyTorch, right?
So, and Google is a very big company, right? Yeah.
So all, even if rest
of all the companies not using TensorFlow say
that for, for a, for a reason.
Yeah, Google itself is a very big company
and then it can sustain, it'll
Use, yeah.
Thank you sir. Thank you. Yeah.
Okay. Any other query from anyone?
Yes, sir. For ish? Yes.
Yeah, for, um, three, four
or five tens where four five tens of where we have batch.
So when execution is done, sir,
then it all file batches run at once
or each batch is run separate easily.
No batch by batch.
You have to suppose you have 10 data,
which you have converted into two batch first five data in
batch number one, second five data in batch number two.
So at a time you can process one batch
completely inside the batch.
Also you have five different, uh, you can data, right?
That can be processed parallel. Okay.
So batch by batch you can do the training
and batch by batch loss calculation back perion can happen.
That is the meaning of it. Yeah.
Yes. Thank you.
Any other query from anyone?
Yes, sir. One last question from my end.
So last, uh, semester, you mentioned that
for evaluation you have created an LLM.
Mm-hmm. Rachel.
So, so is it, is it a good time to share that LLMI?
I'll share That whenever you get a chance. Yeah,
Yeah, I'll share that in.
So once I'll be full confidence that it is working,
then see we, I mean,
I just wanna see like how it process multiple inputs
and kind of how it evaluates.
I, I'll definitely show that.
I'll definitely show that in the class.
In fact, assignment, which you will get
for the code based assignment
for building the deep learning model
that also will evaluate this time using that, uh,
using again, the agent itself.
Okay. Not only the summary. Yeah.
Okay. Class summary. Yeah.
So that will, I'll show you that how, how does it work.
Maybe one or other class will be the
demonstration for that itself.
Yeah, demo for that. Gotcha.
Thank you. Any other query?
Sure. So can we have hackathons by, um, from,
I mean using Carle
and all, maybe you can conduct all, all the that, right?
I mean it'll be fun for us also.
Yes. That also we can do
where these are the challenges which you,
which you can solve, like how to build those agents,
which can do the automatic evaluations and all.
And you can submit that that is will be from our side.
And if you're interested in some other hackathon,
which are live by some other,
there are some one other hackathons which are going on we'll
have to see and can suggest you later
on. Okay.
Yeah. So
Questionnaire, Yes, yes, yes,
Yes sir.
We have been hearing a lot about vector database.
So is it something like, uh, a system to uh, store these,
uh, sensors or they are both different systems?
No, no. See, I'll tell you, in the deep learning, most
of the things are answers.
So even when you will start building those, uh,
vector database, which is not part
of this particular course,
you will learn in the LLM large language
model in the next semester.
Uh, the rag part, I know that what you're talking about.
But then there also we use the embeddings vector data
inside the vector database.
We have the embeddings, and again,
embeddings will use the tensor concept.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Uh, is this all okay, so, uh,
then we can conclude.
So I don't see any, any, uh,
summary which we have created for today.
Uh, because uh, the TAs are not on the board as of now.
So by next class that, uh, we can start summary.
Yeah. Next class. Sure.
Sorry, uh, you said Who are the
TAs?
Uh, TAs are, we are still identifying by next one
or two days we'll onboard them.
Okay. Yes sir.
Fine then, then Saturday we'll meet at nine to 10 30.
That is the next class time. Yeah.
Nine to, yeah, just
One question is not related to this course.
So there is a course called generative AI
applications or something.
Is that course part of this semester or next semester?
Uh, next semester.
I, uh, this semester from gen, uh, you don't have
that course from Gen AI basket.
You have two courses, deep learning anyway, common for all.
You have reinforcement learning, that's all.
Okay. Yeah.
So maybe the, some of the, uh,
maybe the IT support person have wrongly
because we are invited for the post, uh, a Oh,
so that is the reason, uh, the some
Oh, we we'll see that.
Okay. I'm not aware about that. What was that?
So, but I will check with, what is that?
Uh, uh,
yeah, you can Sarah.
So we received, uh, a invitation for the three course, uh,
like a, a deep learning reinforcement learning and Gen A.
So, but as per the document, the gen is for, uh, some sort.
So the probably by mistake they have a, uh, invited
for the postal model. Yeah,
Yeah, yeah. I think
the only
that, yeah.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank sir.
Sir.